hi my name is Melissa Hendershot and I'm
a graduate student at UCSF today I'm
here with Jim Farrell who's a professor
at Stanford he's also a member of
several rock bands and today he's going
to talk about his experiences in science
and in music when did you first start
playing music 1964 like we're right in
the Beatles invasion I had this friend
who had a ukulele and he taught me how
to play the ukulele how have you managed
to integrate music into your life
outside of science and sort of fit that
into all of your scientific endeavors
it's hard to fit it into either you know
normal life or in the scientific life
because it does it takes time other
things suffer but it's but but but you
get pleasure out of it and it's a good
thing 23
she must have been an interest in shower
she traveled to a lot of strange places
and she'll only get go I had this other
friend who's dis turn her appetite life
has been curved maybe she just needs a
smile and vacation maybe she needs
something more I think she's there at
you don't like a new set of keys here's
the birds and the trees
sup
but I don't feel so bad
I have another friend who is tired sada
stay away has expired maybe he just
needs some tea and toast maybe he needs
something more I think he's there at you
don't like a new set of genes in the
tree
in fact a few pretty don't you feel
electrical I'm gonna go out do that work
and make my stuff a really good me
so did you play music all through your
graduate career not not quite at all I
up at Medical School presuming that I
was entering the serious grown-up world
where I would do nothing but but study
my histology and pathology and and I was
pretty serious for about two years doing
research and making a little bit of
progress toward my PhD thesis but then
bad things happen in my second year I
said all the premises that that my my
PhD thesis were based on turned out to
be wrong I didn't really have a good
idea for something to work on and some
other bad things happen in my life so I
I thought you know I I just tried this
band thing one last time as a way of
maybe introducing some happiness back
into my life and and it's stuck how did
you meet your bandmates moat most of
them i met back then when I was a
graduate student and so I've known those
people for a long long time I met my
wife back then I was a really important
decision as it turned out that this
decision to to play in a band instead of
devoting myself full time to to my
scholarly pursuits
I like your eyes your eyes open I like
your
your eyes are plainly
like I like your head
your hair is long I like your hair
your hair is with you baby I can I like
your teeth your teeth are clean I like
your tea
your teeth dolly I liked your ears and
also
can you tell us what some of the
inspirations for your songs are well
let's see everybody's suffering was
about the fact that everybody I knew at
that point seemed to be having big
trouble in their lives but I was ok
let's see to linda's was about this
friend of mine who was dating two women
named Linda and love had not worked out
for him I was hoping it would work out
this time and I like your eyes was about
my wife actually because I didn't like
your eyes so that yeah just just basic
songs saying true facts in one line
after another can you tell us about some
of the venues that your band has played
at well we played the biggest maybe that
may be the biggest being the department
of chemical and systems biology's annual
retreat it was fantastic especially when
i was department chair we could we could
make the people dance especially the
young faculty they wouldn't dance no
tenure
with your two lingers howdy keep
you were in love before miss quiet never
loved her but she left you here
day
and you gave your heart too fast and it
took who love to awkwardly it nearly
killed you when she would
hi sashy soft our head is such a mess
and you don't know if you love her
then I performed Oh laughs and it scares
the pants right on you what's the head
so poor boy supposed to do
waving goodbye tonight I know I would
outrun you long ago I
never really sure she loved me and she
loved another two but I nested in here
till she
Dinda segundo ever fly with you the
bluest eyes you ever seen a we live and
I hope she really loves you yes I do
it's hot tub these lenders came through
you
you